it's been gosh almost two whole decades
since firefly went off the air and the
show's fans have been peppered with
false hope
at least once a year ever since rumors
of reunion special
serenity sequels and netflix reboots
have made the rounds like so many
signals you can't stop
nathan phillian cosplayed as captain
reynolds on castle which devotees saw as
a sure sign that the crew would keep
flying soon enough
an mmo was announced in 2013 complete
with voice work from the original cast
but it disappeared without so much as a
sorry we got you all worked up from the
development team
it is therefore with some degree of
caution that the following update is
relayed
word is making the rounds at disney is
working on a firefly reboot
intended for release on its disney plus
streaming service
that update comes courtesy of giant
freaking robot
and while a reminder to do like the who
taught you and not get fooled again
might come as a given the rumour appears
to have legs
it's all thanks to the continuing
downturn in the financial viability
of theatrical releases and a company
wide shift towards more televised
content
firefly which joined the disney vault as
part of the company's
2019 acquisition of all fox
entertainment properties
is seen as a viable universe to explore
given the studio's direct-to-consumer
emphasis but it's not the return of a
beloved cult franchise that's turning
the most heads
it's the rumored disney vacation of the
series that appears to be coming with it
per giant freaking robot source disney's
return to the firefly universe is set to
make some staggering changes
not the least of which is that the
series would reportedly be a hard reboot
recasting and restarting every character
from the beginning
that's bound to draw the ire of die hard
fans as will the studio's proposed plan
to make the new series pg-rated in the
hopes of creating a more family-friendly
end product
firefly in its short-lived run on fox
back in 2002
was a decidedly bleak story defined by
its morally grey plots and
characters in the firefly universe
prostitution is a noble line of work
dogs are eaten and high-ranking boss
battle minions get kicked into turbines
to better make a point
the good guys do bad things and the bad
guys do worse things with frequent
illusions to force brain surgery
wholesale civilian slaughter and sexual
violence factoring into the show's plot
it seems like a peculiar universe to try
and sand the edges off of
but that's reportedly what disney
intends to do
details on the show's production are
slim at the moment with reports that the
firefly reboot is in such early days
that it wasn't yet ready for disney's
recent investors day presentation
perhaps the biggest question on fans
minds will be whether or not original
showrunner and series creator joss
whedon
will be involved given the recent string
of bizarre allegations surrounding the
acclaimed filmmaker
there's no word yet but it seems
unlikely that the show will break up mo
without whedon at least offering his two
cents while brown codes wait for more
news about the rumored reboot
there's still plenty of firefly lore to
explore since the show went off the air
darkhorse and boom studios have produced
dozens of comic book continuations of
the story
written by geek royalty like patton
oswalt and even joss whedon himself
the franchise has spawned novelization
reference books
rpgs board games and a cookbook since
there's untimely removal from the
airwaves
given that the original series only
lasted half a season
the fact that it spawned so much content
might seem impossible
but then again that's what makes it
mighty
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you